معنى الان من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا بك
اللواء فايز يعني مع
تصاعد الان الحديث من اكثر من طرف عن
مفاوضات او عن شروط لاي مفاوضات بين
الطرفين
ميدانيا وعسكريا ما هي احتماليه ان تكون
هناك ضربات من قبل جانب على الاخر وخصوصا
الاجانب الاوكراني لمحاوله تغيير المعادله
على الارض قبل اي تفاوض
يعني من حيث المبدا جميع الحروب تنتهي
باتفاق واتفاق سياسي
وبالتالي
بما انه هذا هو الوضع
المقوم الاساسي
لطبيعه المفاوضات البندقيه او بمعنى اخر
العمليات العسكريه ومدى فاعليه في تحقيق
انجازات تساعد السياسي على طرح الاوراق
التي بين يديه الان خطاب كده الجانبين هو
همم طرح اقصى ما يمكن الحديث عن حدود
1991 وتدمير الجيش الروسي من هذا من
الجانب الاخراني الجانب المقابل يطرح
مفهوم انه هذه الاراضي هي اراضي روسيه اذا
الفجوه كبيره جدا ولكن الوقائع الميدانيه
ستجبر الطرفين على تخفيض سقف التوقع الان
ما هي المعارك بعد خلصوا تحدثنا وتحدث
غيرنا وقلنا لان المنطقه الشرقيه الان ااه
دوم بس جبروجيه هي مركز ثقل العمليات
لماذا لان القوات التي كانت قد تم حشدها
في خلصن وتقدر ب 40,000 جندي روسي ستقسم
الى اقسام قسم لبناء خطه دفاعيه وقسم
للذهاب الى منطقه دون باس وزباروجيا مقابل
ذلك هناك حوالي 90 الى 120,000 في الجانب
الاوكراني هذه القوات سيتم الالقاء على
جزء منها في منطقه دون بس من اجل تحقيق او
تامين المنطقه وارسال قسم الباقي الى
منطقه بهذا السبب نشهد الان عمليات عسكريه
لكن هذه العمليات محدوده جدا من حيث
الانجاز بحيث انها لا تستطيع هذه
الانجازات لا ترقى الى مستوى التاثير على
الوضع السياسي اول وضع التفاؤلذي طيب رغم
استمرار التزويد الغرب لاوكرانيا لواء
فايز بمنظمات دفاع ااا
جوي وغيرها من الاسلحه ظهرت الان الى
السطح قصه نقص ذخائر عسكريا هل الوضع
طبيعي للوضع عادي
يعني في ظل حرب
اعتمد فيها كثافه ناريه غير مسبوقه الا في
الحرب العالميه الثانيه متوقع ان يكون
هناك نقص ولكن هذا نقص لن يؤثر همم بصوره
صارخه على سير العمليات لماذا لان الجانب
الروسي همم لديه مخزوناته
ويستخدم الطائرات من ايران وهناك الحديث
عن جلب المدفعيه من كوريا الشماليه يقابل
ذلك الجانب الاوكراني لديه بعض المخزونات
المحدوده قياسا مع المخزونات الروسيه ولكن
هناك جسر جوي هل الدول الاوروبيه وامريكا
تحديدا ستعاني قد تعاني ولكن بصيغه لا
يؤثر على جاهزيه لماذا يقول هذا الكلام
لان جاهزيه القوات على الخط الاول والثاني
من خطوط امداد القوات الامريكيه
والاوروبيه لن يتم المساج به اذا تقدم على
المساعدات مما يطلق عليها مستودعات الخط
الثالث والتي يتم احتياجها اذا ما دخلت
هذه الدول في حرب طويله الاجل وبالتالي
تمشيط الصناعات العسكريه خاصه في امريكا
بما يتعلق حتى في همم الاسلحه الاقل تقنيه
من المستخدمه لماذا لانها اقل كلفه ولا
تحتاج الرقائق الالكترونيه لهذا السبب لا
اعتقد ان سيكون نقص الذخائر عائق امام
القوات الاخرانيه
ستجبر الاطراف على تخفيض السقف في همم اي
تفاوض اي عمليه تفاضليه ما هي السقوف
برايك
انطلاقا من هذه الوقائع الميدانيه التي
وصل اليها الميدان
والاطراف العسكريه التي يمكن ان يقبل بها
الطرفان الان في اي عمليه تفوضيه
يعني
افرق بين منطقه
القرن تممها
في ايام ستالين الى اوكرانيا في عام في
ثلاثينيات القرن الماضي وبالتالي هي تعتبر
موروث روسي علما كانت موروث عثماني
ولكن قبل قرون لكن في الثلاثيات القرن
الماضي تم ضمها همم في فتره الاتحاد
السوفيتي من قبل الثانيين في تعديل الحدود
كما جرى في كثير من المناطق لهذا السبب
روسيا الان تقول هذه ارض روسيه لقرون ويجب
ان تعود لذا اعتقد ان القارب ستكون خارج
همم سياق المباحثات الان المنطقه الشرقيه
سيكون هناك همم تراجع او اعاده رسم الخطوط
واعاده رسم الصيغه صيغه نظام الحكم يعني
الان دونباس كان هناك اتفاق من ست يعطيها
شيء معين الان هل يتم العوده الى ميس ام
سيتم تقديم امور اضافيه تقنع روسيا لان
روسيا عندما تشن حرب لمده تسعه شهور وتعود
الى عام 2014 وليس عامل 91 ستكون تعني لي
كرامه الجيش الروسي السياسي الروسيه لهذا
السبب لابد ان يقدم شيء ولو في الاطار
السياسي وفي اطار نظام الحكم الجديد